il écoute des coups de feu
sur les passagers ma cliente est morte
sur le coup avec une balle dans la tête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez vu cette histoire
vous rappelez de rumigny kara qui vend
des mails sont assurés et bien
maintenant il ya stéphanie matou qui
après avoir mené des payants pau
a une nouvelle idée la pole de l'été
elle a décidé de mettre sur le marché la
sueur de ses sens on dit souvent on dit
souvent j'ai travaillé à la sueur de
médecins c'est ce que dit bergerac
[Applaudissements]
foot
indoor et oui l'influencé stéphanie
bateau et ses 300 mille abonnés sur un
tas qui pouvaient déjà l'apprécier
chercher des pièces de monnaie dans son
canap prend des cours de piano bande est
donc ses flatulences pour le plus grand
bonheur de certains fans
et c'est donc grâce à ce petit
écouvillon qu'elle arrive à récolter la
transpiration de ces simples 10 50 mille
dollars par semaine en vendant sa et cpu
une seconde 500 dollars pour acheter ça
et envoie un message terrible aux jeunes
parce qu'il ya plein de jeunes qui
prennent ça au premier degré qui se bat
mois plus tôt travaille dans une
entreprise normale et gagner 1500 euros
j'ai vendu mes psv van de l'aude mais ça
gagne 500 $ et c'est extrêmement
dangereux ce qu'elle fait même si c'est
sur le ton de la rigolade font ça très
dangereux qu'elle a vendu tous deux
acteurs
s'étaient bien sûr tu sais que mon côté
et lance un chiffre c'est toujours en
dessous qui disent qu'il ya 400 minutes
c'est pas vrai du tout sens de
vantardise comme ça mais
moi je je je ils font ce qu'ils veulent
non c'est là je suis désolé j'en ai
marre de dire oui les exemples écoutez
moi bien arrêter des cons pour les
acheter mais oui
c'est vrai moi je pense qu'il ya assez
de d' arnaque sur lesquelles on va se
pencher dans ce milieu là que nature
voir une fille qui te dit réellement ce
qu'elle te vends halte dans son père
elle te vend sa soeur s'il ya des
crétins pour acheter ce truc là rue des
fétichistes chou bah pourquoi pas parce
qu'au final elle ment pas sur la
marchandise là où c'est embêtant c'est
que cette fille est en train de mourir
une voix de plus que pour exister et oui
pour faire du buzz ou pour exister
quelque part il faut faire quelque chose
de négatif et dans cette société tout
marie chavanne négatif on
voit jamais tout d'un coup un buzz super
sympa d'une fille yonah reprises et tout
ça c'est fait n'importe quoi à la merde
fait une bêtise frappe quelqu'un et puis
tu as la claquette à me contenir ça
c'est sûr mais place vendôme on crie
tout son génie
du sepa négatif mathieu a way sera
négatif c'est tout c'est aussi le
fantasme de certains et c'est très bien
s'ils ont les moyens qui se paye un
fantasme comme ça plutôt de l'exercer
eux de manière négative là c'est gagnant
pour elle c'est gagnant pour les gens
qui achètent si l'on nous envie c'est un
commerce voir maintenant
guillaume a raison effectivement c'est
que heavy évidemment cette stéphanie là
elle peut éventuellement on gagner un
petit peu d'argent et tout ça elle est
peut-être structurée elle sait se donner
des limites et qu elle qui a une petite
gamine qui dissout ça ouais alors elle
en vendant cp et la transpiration entre
ces sens elle a gagné 10000 20000 mal en
moi qu'est-ce que je peux faire en fait
on créé des monstres mais comme déjà
magnétique qui était venu ici et qui
tout d'un coup est nommé à 900 les
réseaux sociaux crève de retard et c'est
plus grave non mais c'est bien sûr que
c'est plus grave mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que comme on crée du buzz et
ont vite ce besoin qu'on le buzz il va
s'épuiser elle va dire bah finalement il
va falloir que je dois je vends mon
pipier mon caca parce que ça ira
toujours plus loin
samedi soir à paris trois policiers vont
ouvrir le feu sur une voiture qui refuse
de s'arrêter le conducteur a redémarré
en fonçant sur au moins un des
fonctionnaires de police
les agents ont alors tiré simultanément
entre huit et neuf cartouches pour
arrêter le véhicule à son bord quatre
personnes si le conducteur connu des
services de police est grièvement blessé
une des passagères rayhana va mourir sur
le coup il ya des sons de cloche très
très différents on avait la réaction de
jean-luc mélenchon qui a dit qu voilà
vous dira d'ailleurs regardez là des
coups de feu qui ont été tirés sur des
gens qui refusait d'obtempérer c'est à
dire qu'il refusait de s'arrêter alors
c'est condamnable de refusé de s'arrêter
mais leur tirer dessus depuis quand le
refus d'obtempérer mérite des coups de
feu alors dans un premier temps jeu
je souhaite quand même au nom de la
famille que je représente de la victime
et et bien avoir une pensée pour elle
premièrement rayhana première on ne
connaissait pas le conducteur je crois
que c'est un point extrêmement important
à savoir elle ne connaissait pas
deuxièmement rayhana et c'est une jeune
fille qui n'avait pas de casier
judiciaire
parce que on a entendu de tous et bien
l'histoire ça qu'on fait il était un
ordinateur c'est l'app store c'est que
en fait elle est à 6 heures du matin
elle est appelée par sa copine inez qui
le dit voilà on fait un after en boîte
est ce que tu veux venir des terralies
bien sûr je viens pas de souci on va
rejoindre de copains et donc ils se sont
rendus à cet after soirée en boîte de
nuit et de 6h à 9h du matin il s'avère
qu'elle n'avait pas d'argent et plus
d'argent pour prendre un taxi way and
bear et du coup et bien un garçon ce
garçon-là s'est proposé de les ramener
chez elle d'accord le connaissais pas du
tout pas du tout elle monte à la halle
avant à était passager avant et donc il
ya une copine à elle qui monte a là rien
sa copine est derrière elle c'est ça et
puis c'est bien entendu effectivement
dans le son les ondes était de l'autre
côté et là dessus il ya un contrôle de
police parce que l'un d'eux n'avait pas
de ceinture de sécurité
on a su après ses co producteur avaient
un casier qui fait la police que c'est
quelqu'un qui était qui était vraiment
recherché donc il n'avait pas dire ça à
tous ses passagers un bien sûr si bien
absolu de dire qu'il n'a pas le permis
non plus d'ailleurs entre parenthèses
donc du coup qu'est ce qui s'est passé
et ses marais 1 comme un gros courageux
non il est parti d'un telle étude voilà
il prend la fuite parce qu'il veut pas
se faire arrêter et le pavé de ce campus
était recherché par la police il arrive
malheureusement fait malheureusement si
je puis dire parce que je pense à ma
cliente devant un bus et il est coincé
du coup les policiers les trois
policiers en vélo vont vers le véhicule
un policier côté passager passager
passager conducteur et un devant et
s'avère qu'au moment justement où il
veut fuir
celui qui est devant s'extraire du coup
le véhicule a pu se libérer partir et
c'est à ce moment là qu'ils ont tiré
tiré à vue + 2 des coups de pieds de
keane qui couvrent des comptes d'armes
qu'ils écoutent 10 coups de feu sur les
passagers surface en garde et qu'ils ont
tiré à vue dites feu ce qui veut dire
que il y avait des innocents dedans des
gens qui n'avaient rien à voir que ce
conducteur et ma cliente est morte sur
le coup avec une balle dans la tête je
précise et plus plusieurs choses
j'essaie d'être assez assez rapide
parler de bavure m mais je suis un peu
choqué et je vais répondre en même temps
à l'accusation de monsieur mélenchon
qu'on a vu là qui disait depuis quand on
tire sur un refus d'obtempérer mais en
fait depuis 2010 est depuis que dans le
code de sécurité intérieure on à
l'article l 435 tirer un alinéa 4 qui
précise l'usagé des armes et notamment
que les policiers peuvent faire usage de
leurs armes dans le cas d'un refus
d'obtempérer donc voilà déjà c'est pas
une bavure puisqu'ils ont commis leurs
actes dans un cadre légal ils ont fait
ce qu'on leur a appris
quand on fait une intervention comme
ceux ci ont fait ce qu'on appelle une
triangulation autour du véhicule c'est à
dire que vous avez un collègue qui se
passe près interpellé le conducteur un
autre qui se met en protection et le
troisième sont trois protection
également et au moment où le conducteur
reprend la route entre guillemets au
moment où ils réaccélère où il redémarre
ses instantanés chez le policier la cua
un dixième de secondes pour réfléchir à
ce qui va se passer
spontanément quand le véhicule ils vous
foncent dessus vous avez un dixième de
seconde pour savoir qu'est ce que vous
allez faire et là vous pensez à votre
vie à celle de vos collègues et c'est ce
qui explique le tir simultanée des trois
policiers jamais dans votre discours
c'est que vous parliez tout à l'heure de
bavures en ayant quand même la parfaite
connaissance du code de sécurité
intérieure l'enfant vit maintenant
décédé c'était forcément ira mal et ce
n'est pas une bavure mais pas de six
filles c'est dramatique on ne naît pas
tirer à vue sur une voiture à l enfant
qui a renversé devant et qui aurait pu
être fauchés qu'est ce que c'est ça
alors alors là vous pourrez le bonnet
une facture des suppositions mais il a
changé en 2010 c'est ce qu' il ferait
plus ce conducteur ne ne pouvait pas été
une rue extrêmement étroite ne pouvais
pas rouler comme un malade ça n'existait
pas
pourquoi déroulé à sens absolument et au
détriment des passagers au détriment de
la sotra et finalement des passagers qui
était en danger s'est amené avec eux là
cette pochette cette passagère a été
autant victime que désolé m il faut
combien il faut combien de refus
d'obtempérer avec des sens uniques en
plus question que tout d'un coup on
puisse considérer véritablement qui est
en danger mais il en est au troisième
elle a arrêté deux fois déjà je ne vous
le savez interviennent savez je dis
simplement qu'une fois plus vous comme
moi on ne sait pas ce qui s'est passé il
faut impérativement que ces cuvettes
bavure non mais savoir ce s'est passé au
niveau jédir du thé du tir à quel moment
exactement mais rares sont les témoins
les bavures j'ai entendu
simplement que la lumière doit cesser sa
peinture en soit c'est une bavure en
soit en ce sens qu'il ya il ya des morts
une passagère qui n'émet ans maintenant
et ce n'est pas une bavure
alors on va le dire c'est un drame et la
comédie drame doivent être élucidées oui
et c'est pour ça qu'une mule albert
déposés tant que toute la lumière soit
message
couvrez ce sein que je ne saurais voir
c'est la mésaventure qui a vécu jasmin
alors qu'elle visitait le musée du
louvre avec sa soeur son mari et son
bébé ma petite lana cinq mois et demi
avait faim il n'y avait presque personne
dans la salle alors j'ai décidé la
nourrir ici la mère décide alors
d'arrêter son enfant discrètement mais
très vite un agent de sécurité va lui
demander de se rhabiller les corps des
femmes n'ont pas être des corps sexué
par des fautes face à la polémique le
louvre a tenu à s'excuser rappelons les
règles dans l'enceinte de son musée le
règlement de visite interdite absolument
pas d'allaiter dans les salles cette
dame a bien fait nous écrire nous allons
faire un rappel général des consignes et
bien si vous dites passé les anglais
vous restez pas faut dire c'est les
anglais et c'est ce qui m'a gêné la c1
l'aspect provocateur presque au loup il
ya un espace dédié et moi j'en ai un peu
marre qu'on tape sur les agents qui
l'ont interdit parce qu'il pensait que
c'était le règlement il est on dire
aller ailleurs etc et je trouve que dans
son témoignage est un peu de provocation
les agents il applique le règlement
non je suis choqué que j'y parle de
provocation en quoi c'est une
provocation de donner le sein à son
enfant ça veut dire quoi parce qu'on
voit un bout de sein fait une exhibition
sexuelle fait qu'on arrête tu veux que
les femmes se cachent pour faire quelque
chose de normal et naturel je ne
comprends même pas qu'on puisse être
contre eux et comme on l'a dit c'est
interdit par la loi d'interdire
l'allaitement en public donc cette
agence est scandaleux c'est ce qu'il a
fait d'ailleurs le louvre a condamné son
action ait parlé de provocation jean
fait honteux france donc du coup vous
allez taper sur l'agent qui va se faire
engueuler on vit dans une société en
société c'est à dire qu'on essaie de
tous faire
pour vivre ensemble comme le roquefort
il n'y a pas de trouble en annonçant ce
show kéba sortir un sens dans tout le
monde
non seulement vous parlez pas souri
longtemps que je n'étais pas dans
l'émission mais c'est ça aussi intéressé
par les la paire serbe si beaucoup il
est gentil si nous on fait ce qu'on veut
y améliorer ça ne vous dérange et dans
jeanne dérange qui bat ça me dérange
la question avait été un enfant quel
était le problème qu'est ce qu'est ce
qui la dérange et elle pour faire de m
elle l'a fait elle thann a dit qu'elle
avait besoin de lui faire don de soi
parce qu'on prend deux ou trois grandes
le gam allait mourir dans les trois
secondes non mais je vois pas pourquoi
des phares de chine aux gars il a raison
il a une vocation c'est une bonne volée
c'est pas la peine qu'on est là on est
dans une société on a nos téléphones h24
en main avec des photos relativement
sexuelle même sur instagram et où on
n'est pas choqué de ça et là on fait les
puritains quand une femme donne à manger
à son
nom mais quoi c'est ça la peur que le
sein d'un côté ils te choque pas sur
instagram par contre 2 mais pardon mais
ouvre ton fils je veux voir qu'est ce
qu'il ya comme truc qui peut te
priver les photos sont privés sur ton
téléphone là est leur public devant ne
manquera pas moi c'est pas du tout privé
on est dans une société qui n'est plus
tout choquée par la nudité et là c'est
pas de la nudité mathieu signer enfin
voilà à l'été c'est juste à l'été si une
maman qui donne à manger à son bas avec
un sens
c'est que si la personne sort un petit
peu son son son téton pour donner à
manger à son enfant il faut vraiment
déréglé pour y voir un truc vous
regardez pas m'attendre à chaque fois
que j'ai vu quelqu'un à l'été je tourne
la tête regarde là je suis pas là en
train de regarder comme un sauvage là
elle est au louvre peut-être que c'est
l'endroit parce qu'après prend le bus ça
va marcher à va pas là étaient dans la
rue c'est pas interdit de le faire donc
en quoi ça gêne on dit on dit oui il
faut que les nanas et à la piscine les
seins nus mais t'as pas le droit
d'allaiter maintenant
voilà moi ça me gêne ce que je regarde
c'est parce que toi tu ailles non
mais quand je suis au restaurant quand
on tue au restaurant en train de manger
que etc et maman sans son sens à table
pour
déconner wilaya s'il te plaît non mais
c'est vrai
[Rires]
j'aime avec qui tu bouffes
et le dit laurent sont les terribles
victimes de ces squatters une nouvelle
affaire de maison squattée tout est
compliqué malgré les lois qui existent
alors qu'ils ont signé l'acte de vente
de leur maison en essonne impossible de
poser leurs cartons voilà ils ont changé
les clés donc je peux rien faire c'est
fermé et il est impossible pour eux
d'agir seul ce soir ils ont décidé de
témoigner dans tpm b pour tenter de
récupérer leurs maisons voilà donc est
ce qu'ils peuvent visiter la maison vous
aimez bien la maison tout va bien c'est
ça on hésite la maison en septembre
dernier d'accord on y en tirant
plusieurs fois on with it on
on kiffe oui on quitte la maison est
vide complètement vide il ya un matelas
au sol d'accord voilà je la visite
plusieurs fois tout va bien jusque là
tout va bien d'accord donc là vous
vous décidez d'acheter la maison fait
une offre l'offre est acceptée vous
faites un crédit et vous vous avez la
maison à disposition à partir de quand
oui donc c'est ça on avait eu les clés
quand vous avez les clés compte de la
cia jours de
vacances le 19 mai d'accord donc c'était
a été dernièrement il a même pas un mois
là vous avez les clés qu'est ce qui se
passe vous vous rendez dans la maison
donc ça donc là qu'est ce qui se passe
on y va tout de suite bien sûr bah oui
normal vous avez envie 20 et vue oui
j'avais des copains qui étaient avec moi
on avait prévu de faire un barbecue pour
fêter ça on se rend là-bas voilà on
trouve on trouve la maison comme ça la
voiture les rideaux un chien
les vélos des patinettes
donc lâché
sur tf1 c'est normal voilà je demande un
petit peu à jouve le portillon je range
est ok je demande demande explications
que bonjour et qui va vous tomber sur
qui je tombe sur un enfant je demande à
avoir un des parents jeudi ap ap les
gendarmes ils sont au courant c'est chez
moi voilà donc chose que j'ai fait j'ai
appelé les gendarmes d'accord et ils
m'ont confirmé que j'étais bien le
propriétaire mais que de là il s engager
une longue procédure parce que ils
étaient ils étaient finalement chez lui
lors de fouilles
dans l'appartement alors laissons 6,6
donc elles elles sont trois enfants et
quatre 4 enfants et autres enfants et
deux adultes d'accord plus le chien donc
là
qu'est ce que vous vous dites tous les
deux dit ces incendies dans une histoire
incroyable c'est incroyable à ce qui se
passe j'ai les gendarmes ont fini par
nous dire gentiment de partir d'accords
à huy de partir de chez vous ah oui de
partir il a fallu jouer des lois essayer
de nous rentrer et en fait on s'est dit
qu'une fois nous on allait être entré
peut-être qu'ils n'allaient pas pouvoir
nous sortir et s'étonner qu'on est les
vrais propriétaires essayer ça vous avez
essayé d'y aller quand de gaieté quand
il ya une personne à la maison n'ont
même pas quand il était là à y rentrer
et je me suis dit je vais escalader
malgré le chien malgré malgré qu'ils
soient là et je voudrais le portillon et
puis on va se mettre dedans map les
gendarmes on va dire bah comment on fait
du coup là alors venez je suis
propriétaire il est vraiment il est chez
lui aussi vous allez vivre l'église à
vous avez fait vous avez si vous avez
fait ça on l'a fait alors bye nous
envieraient nous non on parle un petit
peu avec les gendarmes ont dit mais
comment on va pouvoir régler cette
histoire la commission comment que ça va
se finir parce qu'au bout d'un moment il
va falloir faire quelque chose venez
déposer une main courante a alors née
une main courante on fait quoi que la
main courante bon on a déposé une main
courante on a fait constater un huissier
et voilà ils écoutent ce qu'ils ont fait
ce qu'ils avaient à leur dire et voilà
après il rédige un rapport qui nous a
transmis et kiki et nous a dit qu'il
allait engager une procédure
de la n10 veut il faut aller porter
plainte la main à la main à la main
commente ne suffit pas il faut aller
porter plainte je vers la gendarmerie
j'essaie de porter plainte ils veulent
pas prendre notre place
quoi qu'ils veulent pas prendre notre
plainte parce qu'il serait arrivé avant
que ce soit neutre notre domicile au
[ __ ] donc leurs 19 quand je suis
arrivé j'étais déjà là donc ça signifie
que lorsque j'étais en train de signer
était déjà là donc avant que ce soit
réellement chez moi il était déjà là
c'est un peu gênant au courant de la
faire il lui a dit il le dit quoi le
maire
je sais pas trop ce qui se sent heureux
de mon tour est ce que nous on a été
voir le maire également d'un combat bien
sûr mais qu'est ce qui vous a dit une
mère qui soutenait mais qu'on soit il
savait pas réellement quoi faire lui
dans cette situation qui ne pouvait pas
intervenir directement sur ça c'est la
préfecture carrément un moment où vous
avez pensé à aller sortir manier les
enfants c'est compliqué il ya d anvers
non m enfants non mais la question est
simple d'accord moi j'ai pensé oui ou
non vous êtes propriétaire du bien
certes mais c'est pas votre domicile aux
termes de la loi un domicile c'est un
andalou on habite réellement c'est à
dire avec des meubles avec du linge etc
et ont allaité c'est pas votre domicile
alors que lui 6 aussi incroyable que ça
puisse paraître les 100 titres ce qui a
eu déjà des cas où il ya des maîtres sur
lui les ont sortis et qu'après bon moi
c'est ça c'est pas vrai ski puisqu'elle
est le squatteur pas les porter plainte
argué que je suis en retraite maintenant
je peux le dire je les fais un d'accord
cette affection pour elle aura plus donc
a longtemps ça va arriver hélas là ce
soir il ya eu un tweet du ministre de
l'intérieur non gérald darmanin qui
vient de dire cette situation est
inacceptable
avec donc nous demandons immédiatement
avec le voilà immédiatement au préfet 91
d'engager la procédure de l'article 38
de la loi dalo pour une évacuation
rapide des occupants illégaux dont qui
les retient à 38 ce qu'est ce c'est un
fait ça c'est la dernière loi
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous de
vous y croyez maintenant laurent elodie
vous move n'y croyez vous dites encore
ça va être encore eu autant vous n'êtes
pas dedans vous n'y croyez pas tant que
c'est pas de danger croît pas moi
vraiment là pour l'instant vous très
content de ce qu'a fait monsieur le
ministre oui mais mais tant que je suis
pas dedans pour moi ce sera fini je
demain 17h05 ils sont censées avoir
quitté les lieux vous allez me tenir au
courant quand même devant donc la tomate
17h05 vous êtes en train de faire 17h06
est un barbecue
johnny depp était lui tranquille ou au
royaume uni avec des anglais déchaînés
justement pendant son voyage en
angleterre que le verdict de son procès
est tombé l'actrice a été reconnu
coupable et condamné à versé 15 millions
de dollars de dommages et intérêts à
l'acteur ont fêté ça l'acteur de pirates
des caraïbes s'est rendu à birmingham
dans un petit restaurant indien pour
inviter 20 pote à lui on ne sait pas
trop ce qu'ils ont bouffé mais tout ce
qu'on sait c'est qu'il a refait la
soirée des restaurateurs avec une note
de 60 mille balles marchante millions
soit franchement les étaient une
vingtaine ils ont privatisé le resto est
ce qui explique que l'addition est assez
élevé c'est qu'ils ont un menu spécial
ils ont créé énormément de vin de
caupenne le champagne plus plusieurs
milliers d'euros de pourboire donc 60
millions ça fait 3000 euros c'est non
c'est pourquoi il a dû avoir des
bouteilles traitant qu il est temps qu
on vous attend est à 7000 euros thank
you sign
comme ils ont privatisé le lieu est que
ce soir là il y avait 400 couverts pour
privatiser ils ont payé 25 mille livres
de privatisation du lieu sacré on sait
pas à quoi des livres de toi alors par
exemple à sait combien 25 min
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]